OWEN: OK.
Welcome to Authors@Google.
Thanks everybody for coming.
This is the second
talk I've arranged,
and so I'm really happy
to have you all here.
For the past 15
years, David Mindell
has been combining engineering
and historical research
to investigate the evolution
of humans' relationships
to machines.
His engineering work
has been primarily
in the field of deep ocean
robotics and archaeology.
He's founder and director of
MIT's Deep Water Archaeology
Research Group, focused
on exploring the deepest
parts of the world's oceans.
As a research engineer at Woods
Hole Oceanographic Institute,
he developed the control
system and pilot interface
for the Jason
submersible vehicle.
His most recent book, which you
will find scattered around--
"Digital Apollo"-- explores
how human pilots and automated
systems worked together
to put a man on the moon.
His current research
involves the Laboratory
for Automation,
Robotics and Society,
which examines
human-machine relationships
in extreme
environments, including
the deep sea, but also space
flight, military robotics,
aviation, and surgery.
Here today to talk about some of
his latest work, David Mindell.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID MINDELL: Thank you, Owen.
Thanks for inviting me.
Hello to everyone online.
As Owen mentioned,
I've been working
on robotics in extreme
environments for a long time.
And the talk I'm
gonna give today
is observations-- things
we can learn from autonomy
and robotics in extreme
environments that
are helpful to more terrestrial
and everyday environments
in which, as you all know,
autonomy and robotics are
coming.
Driverless cars, robotic
surgery, practically
any place where the
human relationship
to a particular task is
changed or troubled by robots.
This is a sort of
precis of a book I'm
working on that will be out
next year called "Our Robots,
Ourselves-- How Robots and
Autonomy are Transforming
Human Experience"
from Viking Penguin.
So this is a kind of 20,000
foot, or 250,000 mile overview,
of that book.
And I'll start with a headline
from the Wall Street Journal
Online.
This is about April 5, so
just about a month ago.
"Navy Drones with a
Mind of Their Own."
"Newly unveiled
technology runs on tablets
and enables unmanned
aircraft," for the picture
of this aircraft called
AACUS, which was sponsored by
the Navy.
And I'll come back to
this later on in the talk.
But I want to just
sort of highlight
the headline, "Navy Drones
with a Mind of Their Own."
Kind of classic press coverage
of autonomous systems,
encapsulating in those few words
all of the stereotypes and kind
of media imagery
around autonomy, which
is very broadly held not
just by reporters, but also
by the public.
Then I'm going to
back up a little bit
and go back into
the undersea realm
and start with this family tree
of vehicles which comes out
of the Woods Hole
Oceanographic Institute.
And it starts down at the
bottom with manned submersibles
like Alvin, which you
may well have heard of.
I'll say more about
that in a minute.
Goes on to the
remote vehicles that
are tethered and cabled
to the ship, like Jason.
Owen mentioned that I
worked on Jason for a while.
Some of the more advanced
versions of that.
And then into these autonomous
systems, the REMUS, ABE, SeaBED
Sentry.
Actually Nereus was
just lost last week
at about 10,000
meters-- it imploded.
One of the reasons it's good
to build autonomous vehicles.
The REMUS vehicles found the
wreckage of the Air France 447.
SeaBED and ABE
and now Sentry are
hard at work for the
science [INAUDIBLE]
looking at hydrothermal vents.
And the implication
of this family tree
is there's a kind of autonomous
technological progress
that moves from manned to remote
to unmanned, or autonomous.
And that very much represents
the point of view that I had
and that everyone I worked
with had in the '80s
when we started building
the first remote vehicles.
These were going to be
the wave of the future.
Robots were going to supersede
human visits to the sea floor.
Alvin at that time had been
diving since the early '60s.
So already in the late '80s
it had 25 years of experience,
and brought and still brings
three people to the sea floor
down to about, these
days its 6,000 meters,
and puts the human eyeballs
directly on the seafloor.
And so you have that-- whoops.
I don't want the
[? Boston Marriot ?]
Cambridge-- whatever that is.
So we have this human vehicle.
And the scientist
who led Alvin's use
as a scientific tool during
the late '60s and '70s
was this guy Robert Ballard,
who I'm sure you've heard of.
And in the early
'80s, he actually
came to MIT to one
of my teachers--
Tom Sheridan-- although he
wasn't nearly my teacher yet--
and he helped develop
this idea of telepresence
on the sea floor.
No longer do we
need to send people.
Now we have remote
fiber optic cables.
There's a sort of garage that
maybe has some sonars on it,
hangs off the ship,
and now you've
got a little remote robot
floating around down here.
And this image was
actually published
in "National
Geographic" in 1981.
Ballard said manned
submersibles are obsolete.
Manned submersibles are doomed,
actually, is what he said.
He was quoted in the "Cape
Cod Times" as saying that.
Marked a big split
from the Alvin group.
He went off and started his
own lab to pursue this vision.
One of the early vehicles
from that vision,
which is basically
just the towed sled
part without the robot, was
actually the thing in 1985
that discovered the
wreck of the Titanic.
But most people think Alvin
discovered the Titanic.
And the reason is because
they went back to the Titanic
in 1986.
And the configuration
was Alvin, with
this little, teeny
remote robot Jason
Junior-- it was kind of a
predecessor to the Jason robot.
And Alvin would sit on
the deck of the Titanic
and dive-- Jason
Junior would dive,
remotely controlled
by human operator
with a little Sony
Watchman-- if you ever
remember what
those were-- camera
and actually dive down the
grand staircase of the Titanic.
And I have a chapter in the
book describing that expedition,
because there was
literally this tension
between the remote
robot people and Alvin
people who were worried
about being superseded.
In fact the crew of
the ship baked a cake
with Ballard's quote that said
manned submersible are doomed.
And before they would
let him to dive in Alvin,
they made him eat that
cake, literally forcing
him to eat his words, as
though he was clawing back
to use this, what they
found, very capable
manned submersible.
And then the remote
robot was added to that.
And I put these two
images up, because they're
interesting in that the "Time"
magazine image of the dive
has only Alvin-- doesn't even
show the little robot Jason
Junior.
And the "National
Geographic" image
which was illustrating an
article that Ballard wrote,
has only Jason
Junior and no Alvin.
So you can see there's two
very different interpretations
of that event.
And lest you think--
I mean, these already
brought this event
to public prominence.
But this scene, basically,
is the opening scene
of the second most
highest-grossing film
ever made.
Jim Cameron's film of
"Titanic" reenacts,
in a kind of Hollywood
version, this scene.
So from the kind of late
'80s, early '90s you
have this question being raised
sort of in the public discourse
about what is the value
of remote presence
versus physical presence
on the sea floor.
I joined the group just a year
or two after that expedition
and began working on
this vehicle, Jason,
which has this light
fiber optic cable
that brings electric power and
sends telemetry and video back
up to the surface.
And then later in the '90s, and
much more in the last 10 years,
these autonomous vehicles
have come online.
And what we found
through all this
was that the advantages of the
remote and autonomous vehicles
were not usually the
things we expected.
For example, they weren't
cheaper and they weren't safer.
But they did radically change
the nature of the work.
With the remote
vehicle, it meant
that rather than
having three people
in the sphere of the
submersible-- one of whom
was a pilot, two of whom
were scientist observers--
they would go down
in the morning,
spend all day on the
bottom, come back up,
tell everybody in a
meeting what they saw.
With Jason you had the
entire science party--
maybe 40 people-- watching on
the surface ship in real time.
And it was a very different
kind of collective scientific
experience to do
that exploration,
with really profound
implications.
And it gave you a
tremendous sense
of presence on the
seafloor, not least of it
from all the other people who
you were sharing experience
with, and different
scientists telling you
what you were seeing.
In the case of shipwrecks we've
worked with archaeologists.
Similarly, the
autonomous systems--
the original idea was
you'd send them out
and they'd go do the
thing and then come back.
But parallel with
this was the rise
of the technology
of acoustic modems.
And even if you could only get
low baud rate text messages,
you still always wanted to
stay in touch with this thing
as much as you can.
But that's since developed in
a much more sophisticated sense
of-- autonomous vehicles
in the ocean have,
depending on where
they are, because
of the nature of the
acoustic channels,
you have very different levels
of bandwidth moment to moment,
almost.
And now Woods Hole is
developing optical modems
that are almost
like streetlights.
If you picture one of these
lights kind of hanging down
and then any time you're within
seeing range of that light
you can get 10 megabits per
second of data back and forth,
and then you may swim away.
And that, so you're
really always
in this mode of sort of
autonomous and sort of remotely
controlled.
Then you zoom out
a little bit, as we
had to with these
vehicles, and think
about what's really going on.
You have a ship out
there on the ocean,
and the vehicle dives maybe
for a day and comes back,
and then you take off the data,
and you recharge batteries,
and send it back out again.
Maybe even have two or three
of those vehicles working.
And so what you really have
is a collaborative system
with a manned vehicle--
i.e., a ship-- one
of the oldest, most
traditional manned
vehicles we've ever had--
and an autonomous vehicle.
And what you call autonomy
is really fairly well bounded
between these episodes
of human intervention.
So that's one of
the early lessons.
And this image was actually
Andy Bowen's image--
who was the designer of
the Nereus vehicle, which
as I mentioned was
just lost last week--
captures some of that fuzzy
world where what's human,
what's remote, what's autonomous
is constantly blurring.
And these are not
categories that
are really all that
useful to us anymore.
Again, you have the
acoustics modem here doing
a survey, a kind of optical
spotlight kind of modem,
other kinds of modalities,
maybe there's a buoy
and you exchange with light.
And there's a whole very rich
period right now experimenting
with all these
different combinations.
So lesson number
one is just that
human remote and autonomous
systems are evolving together.
You don't have this kind of
replacement of human systems
by autonomous systems.
And they all interact
and affect each other.
For example, there's a new
Alvin just came out, just
finished its sea
trials actually.
Fully upgraded, has a
new pressure sphere.
All the electronics and the
software in the new Alvin
are taken out of the
autonomous vehicles, right?
So all that software,
all the navigation,
all the interesting sort of slam
modeling of the sea floor that
gets done now gets them
inside the sphere in Alvin.
Changes what it
means to be in Alvin.
Changes what it means to be
physically present on the sea
floor.
But how is Alvin not
a autonomous vehicle
that you sit inside?
OK?
And that's a bigger question
for a lot of other arenas.
How is a modern jet liner
not an autonomous vehicle
that you sit inside?
And those questions
are constantly
coming up in the
aviation domain as well.
So what the book does, it
starts with the undersea story,
but then goes into three other
extreme environments really.
One is remote warfare with the
Predator and Reaper operators
who are doing things very very
similar to what we learned how
to do undersea, although
the implications are
quite different.
Then in the aviation
domain, and what's
happening in commercial aviation
with different technology
in the cockpits--
heads-up displays,
particularly synthetic
vision displays.
How is this changing the roles
of what the pilots are doing?
How might it change
in the future?
What are the cautions
we've learned?
Because there have been
some really scary accidents
around that.
And then into the remote
spaceflight realm, particularly
looking at the Apollo
landings which I'll come to,
which I've already
written about,
and the Mars exploration
rovers where,
even with a 20 minute
time delay, and relatively
limited data bandwidth,
the scientists who
work on that stuff still have
a tremendous sense of presence
in that Martian terrain.
So the sense of presence is
not exclusively dependent
on Hi-Def video and
real time feedback.
So the overall goal
is to move beyond some
of what I'm calling these
kind of 20th century
ideas of present versus
not present, manned versus
unmanned, human operated
versus autonomous,
but rather thinking about mixes
of all these things, new ways
of being present,
and the questions I'm
interested in asking is,
where are the people?
What are they doing?
When are they doing it-- in
many cases what you consider
autonomy really has to
do with human intention
and being uploaded
and programmed
at an earlier point in
time before it's executed.
Through what bandwidth,
and what time delays?
And then the last one,
which is the kicker
for a lot of the really
passionate stuff,
is why does it matter and
why should anyone care?
It turns out people care a lot.
Even if the cognitive
experience of warfare operating
through a remote
vehicle 6,000 miles away
is very, very similar to
the cognitive experience
of operating the
same sort of system
from an aircraft at 35,000 feet.
The physical
presence of the body
has a huge cultural
weight around it.
And for one, you get flight
time and you can receive combat
medals, and for the
other you can't.
And again-- and this is
sort of again extrapolating
from the undersea world,
but there are many,
many other examples
of it-- is that what
we think of as
autonomy really needs
to be rethought
of as opposed to,
this is an autonomous vehicle.
It's a robot in the kind
of science fiction sense
and it's going to go out
there and do its own stuff.
It's really-- autonomy is
something that's bounded,
and it lives in the time domain
as a function of bandwidth
and human context and the nature
of the task at any given point.
That echoes a
report, for example,
from the Defense
Science Board in 2013:
"All autonomous systems are
joint human machine cognitive
systems.
There are no fully
autonomous systems,
just as there are no fully
autonomous soldiers, sailors,
airmen or marines."
And then you can add to that
engineers, undersea explorers,
astronauts automobile
drivers, doctors, surgeons--
everybody's operating
within a network,
and the key is to understand
what is that network,
and how does it work?
So I'll give you a little
excerpt from my previous book
"Digital Apollo,"
that Owen mentioned,
which illustrates some of this.
And one of the real
observations from that system,
although it's from many,
many others as well,
is that when we think we have
a system that's autonomous
they tend to work,
well, kind of notionally
in a laboratory environment.
R&D loves autonomy.
But as you get closer
to real environments,
where there are real lives at
stake and resources at risk,
human interventions tend to
be added at critical points.
And so this is
one of the reasons
I think that you
look at autonomy--
and people used to say this
about AI-- sort of like, five
years into the future, always
has been, always ever will.
Because it's much
easier to imagine it
in a demonstration
kind of setting.
And this is not an
ontological argument.
This is an empirical argument
from tens and tens of studies
that I've done of different
autonomous systems
over many decades,
which is that as lives
are at stake, as the
stakes get raised,
people naturally put
in different kinds
of human approvals.
Again what that means
is, the autonomy that we
find in systems tends to be
bounded in the time domain.
Not to say that things
aren't acting in certain ways
automatically, but they tend to
be bounded in the time domain.
Classic example is
the lunar landing
this is-- the last
200 pages of my book
are all about the design
of the last 10 minutes
and the execution of the last
10 minutes of the landing,
starting from 50,000 feet.
You may well know that the
computers and the software
for this system were designed
within a mile of this spot
at what is now the Draper
Labs, what was then
the MIT Instrumentation Lab.
And when MIT first got the
contract they said, no problem!
We can build a computer
to land on the moon.
And NASA said,
what's the interface?
And they said well
the interface,
all it needs is
two buttons, right?
One button is,
"Take me to moon,"
and one button is,
"Take me home."
OK.
There again, that's
the original notion
from the kind of
laboratory view out of what
the autonomy of the
lunar landing could be.
It turned out that that was
unacceptable for systems
that had people on board.
And, in the end, there
was a very, very rich set
of interactions between
the human and the machine.
Now interestingly,
another one of the lessons
which I'll come to
appears here, which
is that it was actually
technologically much
easier to make a fully
autonomous landing on the moon
than to make one that
carried a person in it.
In fact, Apollo 12 landed
within 100 yards of Surveyor 3,
which was an unmanned
spacecraft, a robot, that
had landed before Neil Armstrong
landed on the moon under-- it
was also sort of
remotely controlled,
but it was perfectly easy
to do-- not perfectly easy--
but it was, you're
perfectly capable to do
a unmanned landing on the moon
and much simpler in many ways
than a man landing on
the moon-- again, because
of all the sort of
baggage that comes along,
but also just the natural safety
and ethical considerations
of what are you going to do with
a system that could potentially
kill people.
This image is actually
replayed on the cover
of the book, although
not as clearly.
And this is what the
lunar module cockpit
looked like from Neil
Armstrong's point of view
at the moment that he
reached up to turn off
the automatic targeting
system that he had been given
and land the spacecraft in a
kind of semi-automatic mode.
This is the scene that opens the
book and sort of the whole book
kind of orients around
why did this happen.
This image is actually computer
graphic image made for me
by a guy named
John Knoll, who is
the chief animator at
Industrial Light and Magic.
Also you may know him as
one of the two founders
with his brother
of-- or creators
of what became Adobe Photoshop.
And it's a historical
document in that
every switch and every light
and every piece of data
represented there is as
accurate as we could make it.
And you can see the
crater outside the moon.
Armstrong said, "I
turned off the automatic
targeting because the
computer was taking us
into a rocky area,
and I needed to tell
it to go to a smooth
spot that I could see."
And that explanation, which is
echoed almost exactly verbatim
on all of the following five
Apollo landings, where they all
turned off the same
targeting system at right
about the same spot, really
is an inadequate explanation
for that, because the
automatic targeting
system-- I don't
have an image of it--
was designed to allow them
to interact with the computer
and sort of set a landing set
point based on looking out
the window.
You can see these little
gradations just barely there.
It was a kind of passive
heads-up display.
And he could actually jog the
intended landing spot around
with his joystick as
many times as he wanted.
And every time he
did, the computer
would recalculate a
parabolic trajectory
and bring him to that spot.
And that system was
designed so that it
would converge on
a nice smooth area.
That's the system he turned off.
He ended up landing in
attitude hold mode, which
had an automatic
rate of descent,
so it was by no means manual.
But the "New York
Times" the next day
said all praise the human
intervention in the system.
People still have a role to play
in the grand flow of history.
Wonderful extrapolation
of the biggest thing
from the smallest moment.
And so here again you come to
this less than-- that greater
autonomy is often an easier
problem than autonomy
with rich human involvement
with a system, which requires
more sophisticated technology.
And a good example
of this from the '60s
is the Soviet
spacecraft at the time
all had analog
electronic control loops.
And therefore they were
very highly automated.
It was not easy to make those
control loops places where
the human could
really intervene.
It was a radical very
forward-looking step
in the Apollo computer to
put integrated circuits
and make it a general
purpose digital computer
and have it software
programmable and all that.
But one of the
things that enabled
was a lot richer interaction
between the crews.
And so I'll show you just
a little bit of one way
I'm trying to learn how to
depict this graphically.
And my post-doc and
Yanni Loukissas and I
put together this app
which is a-- basically we
got the raw downlink
from the LEM
from one of the Draper engineers
who had it on microfilm
in his basement, something
that NASA didn't have.
We scanned it and OCR'd it, and
then reprocessed all the data,
including the audio into this
sort of richer view of how
the system actually worked.
And what you're seeing here is
time goes from left to right,
as does the distance across
the surface of the moon.
And then the y-axis
is a log scale
of altitude from the
surface of the moon.
So the orange dots represent the
lunar module about 10 to the 4
1/2 from the moon at that
50,000 foot parking orbit.
The slightly less orange
dots are the Columbia,
the service module, at
about 10 to the 5 1/2.
And then 10 to the 9th feet
above the moon is Houston.
And each of these dots
represents an utterance
by the crew in one
of those spots,
and then the lines
are links when
they have a kind of call
and response relationship.
And then, up here you
see the utterances
from all the entire
ground control
team, starting with the
flight director here.
And so what this
little viewer allows
you to do is sort
of play through
and scan through-- and down at
the bottom here I should add,
in fact, it's rare--
I have not yet
given a talk on this where
the projector could actually
display this part of the
screen, but yours happily
does-- is the raw data from the
computer-- in this case it's
pitch-- and these are
various other computer modes
being indicated in the software.
And then there's a
little interaction
where you can kind of turn off
or turn on any of these pieces
at any given point.
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
ASTRONAUT (ON
PLAYBACK) [INAUDIBLE].
DAVID MINDELL: And you
can kinda play through--
of course there's this
famous 1202 program alarm,
and I won't go
through it all here,
but you can play through the
interactions between the crew
and the ground, and you can
see, among other things,
the vehicle becomes
a lot more autonomous
in the last few moments
before the landing,
as the ground kind of shuts up.
But Aldrin and Armstrong
were still very much talking
to each other, and
the data's all still
being downloaded to the
ground, and these are all
their various
interpretations of the data.
I'll just let this
play for a second.
BUZZ ALDRIN (ON PLAYBACK):
40 feet, down 2 1/2.
Picking up some dust.
30 feet.
2 1/2 down.
Four forward.
Drifting to the right a little.
[INAUDIBLE]
30 second [INAUDIBLE].
Contact light.
OK.
Engine stop.
ACA out of detent.
Mode control both auto.
Descent engine
command override off.
Engine arm off.
413 is in.
MISSION CONTROL (ON PLAYBACK):
We copy you down, Eagle.
NEIL ARMSTRONG (ON
PLAYBACK): Houston.
Tranquility Base here.
The Eagle has landed.
MISSION CONTROL (ON PLAYBACK):
Roger, twan-- tranquility.
We copy you on the ground.
You've got a bunch of
guys about to turn blue.
We're breathing again!
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DAVID MINDELL: So
that's the part
that everybody's
most familiar with.
But you can also see here, if
this is the pitched values here
actually, this is where
Armstrong turns off
the automatic
targeting, and then
goes through some pretty
wild pitch gyrations--
he himself called them spastic--
as he tried to kind of get
control of the thing and
get over this crater.
And I had never had-- actually
I produced this visualization
after I wrote the book.
So I didn't have it
when I did the book.
But there was never really a
way before to kind of understand
this data all coordinated
with the audio data
and the trajectory data.
And so it's just a
kind of early attempt
to say, how do we
represent visually
this rich sense of
autonomy, and how
control is traded in
real time, back and forth
through these systems.
And then I'm also
interested in how
does that help you think
about designing systems
in the future.
Also did a similar study
of heads-up displays
in commercial airline
cockpits, which
there's a lot of debate about.
There's actually a
lot of debate about
whether airlines
want to spend money
on automatic landing, which
has been around since the '60s,
and it's a pretty robust
system, but quite expensive,
and keeps them rather
far out of the loop.
These heads-up displays, they're
also not new as an invention,
but they've come a long
way in the last 10 years,
and they're becoming
very practical.
And they give the pilots
a much better sense
of being involved
with the energy
state of the aircraft
at critical moments.
And you can go back and look
at-- even the Air France
crash-- but certainly
the Asiana crash
that happened in San
Francisco last summer--
there's a crash outside
of Amsterdam in 2009--
any number of these
crashes-- there's
a good argument that they
would have been avoided
if the pilots had been looking
through the heads-up display.
And the key thing there
is the head-up display
is not simply a representation
of the data that's down below,
but actually imposes
a flight path vector
on the scene the
pilot's looking at,
which is a kind of
aggregate-- actually
one of the engineers who
created the code for it calls it
"a manufactured
product," which I love,
because it's an aggregate
of a lot of flight data
that's filtered and
smoothed in such a way
that a human can follow it.
And if the pilot looks at
that flight path vector
and puts it on the end
of the runway, that's
where the airplane's
going to go, full stop.
I mean, it's just
as simple as that.
And amongst the pilots,
we did a whole project
interviewing pilots
from European airline
and American cargo airlines.
There's a lot of debate
about whether that represents
a different way to fly or
not, and whether it changes
the nature of their
task, in what ways,
and what the advantages
and disadvantages are.
So I'll come back
now to this "Navy
Drones with a Mind
of Their Own."
And this is really
interesting to me
because I was heavily
involved in this project.
It's a project done by Aurora
Flight Sciences, who is just
over here in the
next building, and it
was a Office of Naval
Research Project.
And the goal was to build a
full-size autonomous cargo
helicopter.
The chief of Naval
Research had, Amazon, I'll
give you a two pound book.
I'll give you 1,200
pounds of supplies.
And that was the goal.
And originally the sort
of assignment from ONR
was make this thing fully
autonomous with absolutely
minimal dependence on a
pilot or a human operator.
And even just to get it to the
point of a demo, piece by piece
that autonomy again
got punctuated
with human approvals.
So let me give
you an explanation
of what this slide is.
The vehicle's
intended to come in.
It has a super duper
amazing LIDAR on it
that was built for us by
Sanjiv Singh and his group
at Carnegie Mellon.
And basically can scan the area,
combine it with optical data,
identify flat spots that
have certain characteristics
conducive to the aircraft
landing, and then come in
and land.
And here's a low-resolution
image of the map
that it might make, some
depictions of that LIDAR.
And here again, to do
this fully autonomously
is relatively straightforward.
In fact, Sanjiv's group
at Carnegie Mellon
had already done that
fully autonomously.
But remember what you're looking
at in a real application.
Here you've got a whole
group of people standing
around, plus a whole--
maybe their little compound
and their equipment--
and then you've
got this 3,500, 4,500,
5,500 pound helicopter
under autonomous
control screaming
at them at full speed.
And one of the assignments--
one of the specs
was-- you couldn't come up and
sort of hover around and scan
the thing.
You had to come in at what they
call a tactical landing, which
is basically 90 knots and a
very, very steep descent angle
and very fast.
Terrifying to the
people on the ground!
They don't know what the
autonomy is going to do.
These are all people who
have worked in Afghanistan.
We did a lot of interviewing
with them in Iraq.
And they've seen
autonomous vehicles
flying around where they have no
idea what they're going to do.
You had to give them both a set
of approvals and rejections,
and also give the basic
vehicle a kind of autonomy
that the people could relate to
so that they would understand
what it was going to do.
Down here on the left side
you see a little iPad mini
interface that gives this
radically simplified sense
of what the
vehicle's states are.
In fact, I think there's
only three of them.
And as the vehicle
comes in it has
to accomplish what we call a
negotiation between the person
on the ground and
the vehicle itself.
I want to land-- you
ask me the land there.
That site isn't OK, for one
reason or another-- the trees
are too close.
I want to land there.
That looks good.
Is that acceptable to you?
Yes or no?
And originally we had
very complex ideas
for how that
negotiation might go
in the midst of the
tactical landing.
Given all the speeds
and physics and sensors,
you had less than 30
seconds to accomplish
that whole conversation.
So that put real
limits on how rich
that interaction
was going to be.
But even for the
Navy test range where
we did this-- we've
never demonstrated this,
it was just demonstrated
in February--
you had to have all kinds
of safety considerations
just to do it in a
test setting, much less
with real people
standing underneath it.
Here's an image
of the helicopter.
It's a Boeing Little
Bird that's been modified
to be fully fly-by-wire
with the LIDAR on the front.
And then instead
of carrying people,
it carries this enormous
computer rack in the back.
And here's the marine
on the ground who's
supposed to be able to conduct
that conversation with 15
minutes of training.
And what you ended
up having to do
was create a basic-- this
is really not all that clear
and the details don't matter--
but the basic mission manager
model, which was modeled
in MATLAB Stateflow,
is the state machine
of, I'm coming in.
I'm either going to land
or I'm not going to land.
If I don't land,
I may come around
for one more pass or
I may go off and hold,
and give you this option.
And that state machine
had to be something
that the human could
understand easily, intuitively,
and quickly.
It couldn't be this
rich, multilayered thing.
And we ended up creating
that state machine
and then autocoding it into
the autonomy, and also then,
as a crude working model
and MATLAB of the GUI,
before operating the state
machine directly, and then
porting that into the
kind of iPad interface.
So this was a bit
of an experiment,
although it worked
very well in saying,
let's make sure that the
issues on the human autonomy
interaction are not
interface issues per se.
They're issues about how
the core autonomy behaves
at its most fundamental level.
And you need to be thinking
about all that, and all
that interaction, in
this very early sort
of pre-coding phase in a way.
And I'll just
encapsulate that saying,
if you want the human
to trust the system,
they have to have a mental
model that's simple enough
that they can relate to it.
And that actually puts
limits on the complexity
of the internal state.
You can't have the thing
doing too much that people
aren't going to predict.
The marines we
talked to-- and it
was pretty detailed kind of
ethnographic study of maybe 60
or 70 people who had operated
these systems-- they said,
the last thing I want to do is
something I don't understand.
Same thing, you asked
airline pilots to say,
have you ever asked of your
flight deck automation,
"What's it doing now?"
Every one of them will say,
yes, I've had that experience.
And then they'll say, that's
only what the beginners say.
The advanced users say, "Oh,
it does that sometimes."
But what then they said is,
what we really want to know
is why did they do it that way?
I don't care even if I don't
like it or I disagree with it.
If I understand something about
the reasoning behind the states
of the autonomy, it's much
easier for me to relate to.
And we've done some
work on actually
trying to communicate that from
an engineering team to pilots.
Then that gets you into
one more observation,
which is, if you really want
the thing to do things that
are what some people would
define as autonomy-- that
is non-deterministic
decision making that's not
predictable from a
set of conditions
that the designers may specify--
there's all these things
that you have to rethink.
And I'll give you just one which
is sort of related-- safety
and verification validation.
Obviously, we fly in
jet liners and airliners
all the time that are
heavily run by software.
They're fly-by-wire, so software
runs the basic control systems.
Those things are certified.
They're triply, quadruply
redundant in some cases.
How does that happen?
Well, that software
is incredibly, highly
deterministic and run through
in a very formalized set
of processes all the different
possible ramifications--
or as many as
people can approach.
You have to prove that every
line of code has been executed,
and the software has
to be-- the way you
make certified software
in the avionics business
is to run through these
very formalized procedures.
There's not even a model
for how to do that when
you have systems where
the decision making may
be non-deterministic,
and you really
don't know what's
going to happen.
The DOD is very--
putting a lot of effort
into trying to think
through that problem,
but it's going to be a huge
issue for moving forward
with higher levels of autonomy
in a traditional sense.
And the similar issues come
around-- liability and testing
and certification.
And even who are your users,
and what are they doing?
Another interesting example
with that autonomous helicopter
is, so we've got this
fancy LIDAR on there.
It'll find you a landing spot
and survey all the approaches
and make sure you
can get out of there
cleanly and land
you automatically.
Well, if I was a
helicopter pilot,
my response would
be, hey, I want
one of those on my helicopter!
It changes what you think
of as a manned helicopter,
and it changes what you think of
as, how what you're doing there
as an operator, now
that the pilot maybe
doesn't have to
worry about that.
There's a supervisory
control system
that can give them
input into those things.
But many helicopter pilots
have, as their central sense
of identity, this sort of
two hands on the stick, two
feet on the pedals,
come in and do
the kind of detailed landing.
So that's where kind of
my final observation.
The big advances I think
that are required coming up
are advances in these human
relationships with systems.
What do we think of as a pilot?
What do we think
of as an explorer?
of as a scientist?
What do we think
of as a warrior?
And these are not
things that are
going to be cracked by
kind of clearer interfaces
or better designs of
interfaces, nor solely
by algorithms, but this whole
kind of system progressing
together and new
kinds of operators,
new kinds of vehicles,
new kinds of systems,
and sort of rethinking
the whole system.
A good example of this
is a current debate
which is-- there's not
a day that it's not
in the paper-- which
is unmanned vehicles
in the national airspace system.
And I think it's
perfectly possible
to imagine a regulatory
framework that
will allow that
to happen, but it
will have to change
what human pilots are
doing in manned
cockpits as well.
That's already changing in
a lot of different ways,
but you'll have to think
about-- differently
about what it means to
operate a manned aircraft.
Which is, again,
already happening.
Already happening for
the last 50 years.
So I'll leave it at that, and
leave some time for questions.
And thanks for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
if you could say something
about the relationship
between humans and automation
when the automation fails.
For example, I was
flying an approach
on the autopilot a few weeks
ago, and I all of a sudden I
went down, and the autopilot
was not at all doing
what it was supposed
to be doing,
and I had to shut it
off and land it myself.
So that was fine.
But in a situation like an
auto landing system where
the response time is
much shorter [INAUDIBLE].
DAVID MINDELL: Yeah, that's
a really good question,
and that's actually
a good example.
And the most
extreme case of that
is the Air France 447 crash,
where the pitot tubes iced up,
the automation doesn't
have the data it needs.
Ironically, it actually
did, and there was no reason
that the system,
given that data,
couldn't basically,
just using GPS guidance,
kind of keep the airplane
straight and level
and bring it down
to a safe altitude
where it was easier to fly.
But that's not how
it was programmed.
Again autonomy is
the assumptions
of the designer being
pushed forward in time.
It was programmed to say, "Oop!
Air data is iced up.
I'm out!
See you guys!
I'm outta here!"
Turns over the entire
system to the crew, who
are a little fatigued, a little
distracted, in bad weather
at night at very
high altitude where
the angle of attack that's
survivable in a big airplane
like that is very, very narrow.
And they actually had control
of it for a minute or two,
and then they lost
control of it.
And that highlights this
case-- and actually many
of these other recent crashes
do-- where automation is always
going to fail.
Stuff just fails.
We know that.
And so you cannot design
a system that keeps people
so distant from it all the
time that they don't have that
ability to intervene.
And I've really, in the
last seven or eight years,
I've changed my opinion on
this a great deal, because I
was a much greater believer
in kind of full autonomy.
And when I started
the Apollo project
I really believed it was the
kind of full just macho-ness
of the pilots that made them
want that ability to intervene
and get hands on the stick.
But over time, and having
talked to them about it,
and looking at other
systems like the shuttle,
I'm a lot more
nuanced about it now.
And so any system you
have-- and again think about
an automobile, or general
aviation aircraft,
very similar.
Actually automobiles, I
think, is a harder case,
because things in
aircraft actually
happen relatively slowly
compared to things in cars,
because the distances
to collision
are greater, even though
the speeds are high.
You've got a lot more
space around you.
The time constants
are just slower.
So any automated
system in a car is
going to have to
be designed such
that if and when it checks
out, the person is going
to be able to intervene in
a way that they will find
it at least safe-able if
not continued drive-able.
And that's a hard problem
that A-- we don't even
understand very well.
Again, Air France, we lost 250
people because of that problem.
Clearly there's a great
interest and a lot
of financial backing to
understanding that problem.
And B-- we're just
beginning to think
about how to do that
in a technical way.
And again, the
Asiana crash seems
to be very much about
pilots losing manual skills,
and then, for various
reasons-- there
was a crash in Buffalo in 2009,
similar story-- when they're
called on to execute
those manual skills,
for a variety of
reasons they atrophy
and they can't
control it manually.
So again, it's an easier problem
to design a system that's
fully autonomous that
never has people in it.
But you won't stake human
lives on that people-- on that
generally.
And my friends just lost their
AUV deep off of New Zealand
last week.
Big deal!
It imploded somebody's gotta
write an insurance check.
But everybody's a little
sad, but not all that sad.
That's a whole different
story than-- actually,
scientists originally
wanted to go
to those trenches
in manned vehicles.
And that would have been
a whole different thing.
Or what you end up doing
is just certifying them
so far that they become
more expensive and whatnot.
So I don't know if that
answers your question but very
much an issue for a general
aviation pilot, too.
And that happens all
the time and there
are concerns in GA craft also.
In fact, after doing this
study with heads-up displays,
I went and put a
synthetic vision system
in my aircraft, because I
don't fly a lot of approaches
at night in the mountains,
which is traditionally
what I had thought it
was for, but it gives you
a flight-path vector.
It's not a heads-up
flight-path vector,
but if you have this
3D display displayed,
then you have a
flight-path vector,
and then you're always
seeing where you're going.
And it's that sort
of aggregate that
helps you just
intuitively appreciate
the energy state
in different ways.
AUDIENCE: So the programming
codes that you are using,
or that you're
allowed to use, is
that still in a state where
dynamic memory application is
not allowed and very
primitive languages?
Or do you have more flexibility
as long as, you know,
people are on board?
DAVID MINDELL: So that's
an interesting question,
because that was a vicious
battle in the Apollo
system was, do you have
a preemptive multitasker,
or do you have a fully
deterministic scheduler?
And they ended up going with
a preemptive multitasker,
although there were
bodies on the floor when
they made that decision.
And it's a-- part of the
book is a story about how
the people who
programmed that feel it
saved the day in the end.
Interestingly,
like the 787, which
is a fully digital
airplane, it has
to use-- it has a fully
deterministic scheduler.
The networks are all
fairly deterministic.
There's no preemptive
communications
on the networks at all.
And so, at some level,
the current state
of certified avionics
is behind where
the Apollo system was in '60s.
Although the last
part of your question
is a very good
one, which is, one
of the real benefits of unmanned
systems-- and we saw this,
again, way back in
the '80s and '90s--
was gee, we would
continue-- Jason would
take two, two and a half hours
to go down into the sea floor,
just because it's very deep.
So would Alvin.
And with Jason, you could
continue working on the code
that whole time.
That was valuable time.
And then before
you hit the bottom
you'd do another download
of the code and-- the code
actually on the vehicle
doesn't do all that much
in a vehicle like that.
Most of it's top
side, but same thing.
Whereas in a certified
manned system,
all that code has to be done
months or years ahead of time.
Alvin, to this day, has no
software in its critical loops.
It's totally hardware-operated
vehicle in its native mode.
So there's no soft sort
of certification at all.
That means that the
unmanned systems tend
to develop more quickly,
and it's a lot easier
to experiment with them, and the
barriers to changing and doing
weird stuff is a lot lower.
And that's what's-- again one
of the things we did not expect
when we started building
remote systems in the ocean.
It turned out to be one
of the great advantages.
AUDIENCE: Would you
say that you are
forced to use tools
that are maybe not
as flexible as you
wish, software-wise?
Are advanced programming
languages allowed?
Isn't that a problem that if you
use a more primitive language
than you would like to,
that there might be a higher
chance of high-level
bugs as [INAUDIBLE]?
DAVID MINDELL: I'm
sure that's true.
That was certainly true
with the Apollo system.
Most of it was written
in assembly code
and-- or in a very primitive
kind of algebraic compiler.
And you can imagine what
it was like to debug that.
That was a long time ago, but.
AUDIENCE: Just wondering.
You've touched a
little bit on cars
a moment ago in
the failure case.
If you can comment on autonomous
cars, or somewhat autonomous
cars, as all these
principles apply to them.
DAVID MINDELL: Sure.
I'm sort of dancing
around that topic,
because it's-- and it sort of
lurks behind the whole book
in a certain sense.
Again, I think-- and I actually,
all I know about the Google car
is what I follow
the press basically.
But to begin with,
and many people
have said this,
car's already have
a lot of these little autonomy
things built into them,
from anti-lock breaks
to cruise control
to automatic transmission.
I mean, what is that
if not a shifting
of the operator's usage?
OK.
And even there, with the
automatic transition,
you still have a Low 1 and a
Low 2 and some more these days.
So even that system,
which is from the '50s,
has an ability for the human
to kind of intervene and push
that loop out.
I think where it
gets challenging is
all the social dimensions of
driving, and all of the ways
that people are making eye
contact with each other,
and perceiving-- and you see
this in the warfare context
actually.
For a machine, or
even for a human
looking through a
soda straw video,
to discern the difference
between a wedding
and a nefarious meeting
with people carrying guns
is not all that easy.
And why?
Because that's a social judgment
that maybe some people can
make, but the people
who are doing the work
are not trained to make
those kind of judgments.
And as you drive a car, you
make those kind of judgments
all the time.
So on the one hand you do
basic collision avoidance.
And that's easier these
days to understand,
how you would automate that.
And on the other hand,
you're constantly
saying, that car looks
a little ratty, has
a lot of dents on it.
I think I'll stay away from it.
That person clearly is
not paying attention
when they're standing at
the stop sign and whatnot.
And how am I going to
interact with other people
on the highway, and whatnot?
And again I think automated
cars are imaginable,
but I think the whole
system is going to change,
and it's going to change
what it means to drive.
And even there, people have
a lot-- it varies a lot, OK?
That's why it's
hard to understand--
people have a lot of
cultural connection
to their identities as drivers.
And some people don't.
Maybe some people don't
care, and they just
want to go from A to B.
That's certainly the case.
Other people love their cars.
They find an extension
of their identity.
They like the feeling of
being in control and whatnot.
And that varies as much
as individual people vary.
And so how do you kind of
negotiate what people want,
and what level they
want to be involved?
But a good example of
this which sort of came up
is automatic landing
in airliners,
where automatic landing requires
a tremendously high amount
of vigilance on the
part of the pilots.
In fact the stress
levels-- there's
been studies that show that
the stress levels on average
are higher than they
are in manual landing,
because it's a little
bit all or nothing.
Either I have nothing to do
and it's just going to land me,
or I have to intervene at
the last possible minute
and bounce off the runway
and go do a go-around.
And I talked to pilots, and
they all say, we like auto land.
If we're tired at the end of
the day, we sort of flick it on
and then it lands for us.
It's not supposed to
be for that, right?
It's supposed to
be-- legally, they're
supposed to have the very
same level of vigilance.
But over time it gets
used in a more what's
the word-- complacent kind
of way, and that's dangerous.
And so-- and airline
pilots, or any pilots,
are highly trained, sort
of technically astute.
They've had a medical exam
in the last six months.
All these things.
And you extend those kind of
complex automation interactions
issues to the world of
millions of drivers.
And to me that's a very
scary thing, actually.
And you look at that
Air France crash
where airline flying is
incredibly, incredibly safe--
much safer already
than driving is.
And yet there are these
corners of the state space
where the people on the machine
get into these wacky loops
and everything just falls
apart and it goes to hell.
And how are we going to
learn about those corners
of the state space in the
human-automated driving system?
That's the question that
really interests me these days.
AUDIENCE: Do you
know of anybody who
is sort of doing fault injection
and testing on the way,
sort of, for humans?
That is, if I know an airline
flight is going to be boring,
I can sort of check
out of manual pilot.
But if there's a chance that
the thing's gonna drill me,
or, it's gonna-- it's gonna,
keeping me interested and, I
can see that being extremely--
I can see as a pilot being
extremely-- feeling untrusted
if I'm put in that situation.
But I can also see it
keeping me on my toes.
Is there anybody who is doing
anything in that direction?
DAVID MINDELL: Actually,
there are some airliners
that have a very crude
form of that, where
like a little warning light goes
on if nothing has been changed
in the last 20 minutes or so.
And that's a very simple form.
I actually think that one of
the frontiers for the work
is to have the systems that
run the aircraft actively
manage the cognition of
the pilot a little more.
Because we know that
people get fatigued,
and we know that people get less
fatigued when they're engaged,
and so there's no
reason the system
can't begin to
engage the people.
Frankly, it might be
better for your pilot
to be watching a
movie than dozing off.
And maybe their favorite
movie is a better way
of keeping them
alert than pretending
against all scientific evidence
that they can spend eight
hours in front of
a bunch of dials
and remain their
level of alertness.
The same thing with
napping, by the way.
We know it's better for people
to nap for brief periods,
and they're more alert.
Yet that's illegal currently
in an airline cockpit--
even though 85% of pilots will
tell you that they do that.
And just those two issues
begin to get around
some of the cultural
baggage around what
do you expect your pilot to be?
You expect them to be this
kind of heroic, active flyer,
and if they're napping
they're clearly checked out--
even though you have
a set of research data
that says people on the
average over 12 hours
are much stronger if they've
napped for 10 minutes here
or 20 minutes there.
And so there's a
whole set of things
that you can begin to imagine--
we're beginning to work on some
of these things--
of actively engaging
the cognitive state
of the operator--
but that requires changing what
you think the operator is--
to be a little bit more
mechanistic, and say,
look you know-- and
this is one of things
about learning to fly
an airplane anyway.
You just learn all these
things about yourself,
where you really are a machine
when it comes to fatigue,
right?
Your performance
just degrades when
you're fatigued-- period, right?
Your visual acuity
just degrades when
you have lower oxygen
levels, period.
You can't sit there and go,
I'm smart-- I can see better,
right?
And so there's a kind of a
cognitive extension of that,
that the regulatory system
and what we expect out
of our pilots is not
remotely caught up with.
And so there's a lot of things
you can imagine like that.
And that may be the
case in cars too,
where, in fact, I think even
some of the lane departure
warning sort of
things-- they only
work if your hands
are on the wheel.
So you can't fall asleep and
let your Mercedes S-Class drive
you.
You have to stay
like this, and that's
one way of keeping
people vigilant.
Does that answer your question?
MALE SPEAKER: OK!
Thank you very much!
DAVID MINDELL: Great!
Thanks for your attention.
Good questions!
[APPLAUSE]